[Musique]
c'est la fin idéale
j'ai 30 ans au journal pour lire l ol
j'espère qu'elles seront sociaux tels
voyages grande portable tenace et
benzema sont putty des ptic romera le
grand et le petit écho de la forêt ces
intrus vrai il y à toutes les
informations à chaque nouvelle édition
on n'a jamais de déception ça vous le
découvrirez dans le tue des cours de
l'offre
[Musique]
[Rires]
voyons voyons
est ce que notre journal est au courant
mais oui mais oui surtout les femmes est
écouté aujourd'hui inauguration du club
mais y met un club doit avoir nous alors
la déco la sienne vous plaît oui
beaucoup
le jus de carotte me plaît à en conclure
frk stars ont bien travaillé il y
trouvait de jus de carotte
je sens que je suis toute rose je devrai
compter ses graines de tournesol la
leçon texte sera encore un piti jugnot
car at il dit ce n'est pas raisonnable
isadora ce n'est pas tous les jours que
ye no good mon club
qu est-ce qu amazon de la cigogne va
venir à l'inauguration
là elle a mal à la tête elle vient va
quand même
elle est trop curieuse je ne crois pas
pas commettre paris un jeu de karaté
double pad et audel l'auto pinceaux et
mademoiselle de la cigogne n'arrive
toujours pas et n'est pas chez ta mère
tu sais c'est une grande dame si les
vagins d'idées sympas alva moi je savais
qu'elle ne viendrait pas elle peut
encore venir ici là comme l'éclair 10
secondes plus tôt marc ayrault la sig en
bref - vale dans la figo pia tu vous
savez on vous attend au club on ne le
dirait pas pourquoi personne n'est venu
me supplier devenus les vrais vous avez
pont pas parce qu'on m'a oublié mais non
mademoiselle de la saison maintenant du
cybus emails tout le monde fait que vous
allez arriver la dernière courbe à fond
pour être une grande dame et je suis là
berne yeux est vrai et ne manque plus
que vous
alors je peux faire mon entrée et un
serviteur en avant zep et c'est ainsi
que mademoiselle de la cigogne fit une
entrée remarquée dans le nouveau club
mademoiselle que des bonnes notes mais
non mais non cher c'est naturel prouvées
nil comme oui je suis navré je suis la
dernière
félicitations les verts castor c'est une
réussite r si c'est la vérité
oh mercy mercy figurer vos bagues mazel
cigognes nous avoir besoin des veaux de
quoi s'agit-il
et bien on voulait qu'elle vendrait pour
trouver un nom à notre club
quelle bonne idée que diriez vous de le
club de la cigogne nuit à pâques et vous
dire mon clip c'est vrai alors pourquoi
pas le club d'isadora il n'y a pas que
moi dans notre club c'est vrai alors je
ne vois pas et les mois avait trouvé le
pea bien club
plusieurs clubs ouais vide et pour le
pire période et faisait des trois clubs
et la fiesta comme houssin
isadora qui grâce à de la colle à ce
très bel endroit du sud
astori toulouse alors aux poules
[Musique]
des bébés
mais bp
c'est vrai c'est vrai on va bien
s'amuser
grâce à ce soutien 4 on sera plus jamais
ça beaver
il ya peu
un jeune homme et lui réussir un tour de
main il paraît que c'est chouette hop va
bientôt faire téléphone pour une
prochaine édition du petit écho de la
soirée